السلام عليكم ورحمه الله هذا موجز الاخبار
من الجزيره اعلنت الولايات المتحده وان
قوتها سنه غاره جويه استهدفت منشات تابعه
لمسمتها جماعات مرتبطه بالحرس الثوري
الايراني في سوريا مساء الخميس واوضحت
وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه ان الرئيس
الامريكيه جو بايدن امر بتنفيذ الهجوم ردا
على مقتل متعاقد امريكي وجرحي اخر واصابه
خمسه جنود الامريكيين في هجوم بمسيره وقع
في وقت سابق على قاعده للتحالف قرب الحسكه
شمال شرقي سوريا من جهتها افدت مواقع
اعلاميه مواليه لنظام السوري بان قصفا
بالطيران استهدف مركز التنميه الريفيه
ومركز الحبوب بمدينه دير الزور والذي
تتمركز فيه مجموعات عسكريه مدعومه من
ايران ما اسرى عن وقوع اصابات
قال النائب رئيس مجلس الامن الروسيه
ان الرئيس بوتين هو من يستطيع تحديد وقت
انتهاء العمليه العسكريه الخزفه في
اوكرانيا واضاف انه لا يمكن استبعاد ذهاب
القوات الروسيه الى
قال الرئيس الاوكراني ان من غير المقبولي
تاخير نقل الاسلحه عن بلاده ووصف كما سماه
التاخير في تزويد بلاده بصواريخ بعيده
المدى بانه كبير بالفعل
افادت وزاره الدفاع الصينيه باختراق
المدمره الامريكيه
مره اخرى اليوم الجمعه المياه الاقليميه
الصينيه دون موافقه الحكومه الصينيه واكدت
الوزارات واجراء قوات الجيش الصيني عمليات
متابعه في المنطقه كما تم تحضير المدمره
الامريكيه ودعوتها للمغادره وطلبت وزاره
الدفاع من الجانب الامريكي ان يوقف مثل
هذه الاعمال الاستفزازيه في المقابل اكدت
البحريه الامريكيه على حريتها وحقوقها
الملاحيه في بحر جنوب الصين
قال وزير الدفاع الامريكيين زياره الرئيس
الصيني لروسيا ارسلت اشاره مقلقه للغايه
اكد ان الصين تمثل تحديا متزيدا لبلاده
واضافه السنه انه يجري تشكيله فريق للتاكد
من تسريع عمليه التسليم الاسلحه الى
اوكرانيا
نشرت شرطه الاحتلال الاسرائيلي صباح اليوم
نحو 2000 من افرادها في انحاء مدينه القدس
قبل ساعات من وصول عشرات الالاف من
الفلسطينيين من الضفه الغربيه المحتله ومن
داخل الخط الاخضر لاداء صلاه اول جمعه في
رمضان في المسجد الاقصى المبارك وكان
الالاف من الفلسطينيين قد ادوا صلاه الفجر
الاولى من اول يوم الجمعه في شهر رمضان
وسط اجراءات فرضتها قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي
اشكركم على متابعه الموجز انا ما كنتم
قابت اوقاتكم بكل خير
[موسيقى]